bonjour
et un grand merci de me recevoir
aujourd'hui je suis
réjouis de pouvoir prendre la parole
avec vous alors aujourd'hui j'ai
introduit un thème sur la mode
circulaire est ce qu'elle peut être
vraiment circulaire et vertueuse et je
vais commencer par une petite anecdote
personnelle
il ya un an jour pour jour j'étais à
vélo dans l'union des républiques de me
anne marque vous connaissez peut-être
sous le nom de birmanie
j'étais venu à vélo avec mon amoureux
depuis la france et on a expérimenté au
travers de ce voyage à vélo
là ce qu'on pourrait appeler la vie
simple on a pédalé tous les jours on a
souvent dormi sous la tente
on a vécu un peu au gré des rencontres
bref on a expérimenté la sobriété
heureuse
j'aimerais d'ailleurs m'arrêter deux
secondes sur cette définition de
sobriété heureuse
c'est elle est définie comme un mode de
vie qu'on choisit volontairement et
celui de qui et de réduire ses
consommations et forcément du coup les
impacts qu'ils sont liés pour qu' on
puisse revenir et se concentrer sur des
valeurs qui sont essentielles qui sont
dites en tout cas comme essentielle à
notre vie alors là vous dites mais
pourquoi elle me parle de tout ça la
mode circulaire le voyage à vélo je vais
je vais y arriver
en fait ce voyage et nous a permis de
découvrir des paysages extraordinaires
de nature de rang d'aller à la rencontre
des gens il a permis aussi de voir ce
que l'homme sait faire de mieux dans l'
architecture notamment et il nous a
aussi et malheureusement ont permis de
voir ce que l'homme sait faire de pire
en fait quand on voit des images comme
ça on commence à prendre conscience et
quand on les vit à prendre conscience de
notre consommation est ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle représente
j'ai une petite question pour vous est
ce que vous savez en moyenne combien en
kilos de vêtements vous consommez par an
donc en sommes aujourd'hui en france en
moyenne 30 kg par habitant et par
personne 30 kg x 67 millions de français
je vous laisse imaginer et dans le
meilleur des cas ces vêtements où ils
vont être recyclés revaloriser qu'un 10
arrivent en fin de vie
vous avez l'image ici en bas à droite
d'un centre de tri et de recyclage de
vêtements seulement 3 kg trois petits
kilos sur ces 30 kg vont être
revalorisées et le reste je vous laisse
ça à peu près imaginer ou est-ce que ça
fini et comment ça se termine donc là
vous êtes peut-être au moment où vous
dire là où là ça fait un peu peur toutes
ces images on marche sur la tête
il va falloir qu'on change les seuls
sinon ça soit sur notre poubelle avant
si oui et souvent quand on voit ce genre
d'image on a tendance à adopter une
posture celle là alors c'est vrai que
c'est plus facile mais c'est pas
forcément plus confortable donc
aujourd'hui je suis venu vous amener un
message qui est positif et qui vous dit
qu'en fait on a plein de solutions on a
plain d'entrepreneurs qui s'engage on a
plein de gens qui sont motivés et qui en
fait nous permettre à nous citoyens de
nous engager tous les jours on a une
superbe méthodologie une méthodologie
con qui se compose de cinq aires qui va
nous permettre au quotidien d'agir mais
surtout de pousser les marques agir et
les inciter à passer à l'action pour que
justement on aille vers quelque chose de
plus circulaire et depuis vertueux la
méthodologie s compose donc de 5 hier le
premier s'est refusé ça fait bizarre de
dire que on commence par là refusé je
vais vous donner un exemple tout simple
on
dans un an on va vous envoyer une
promotion on va vous incité par l'appel
par vous offrir un cadeau
à venir consommer en magasin on va
refuser ce tournoi n'a pas besoin parce
que ces produits à faible valeur
ils sont produits dans des conditions
qu'on connaît pas et ils ont un coût
même si pour nous ils sont gratuits un
coût pour l'environnement autour de nous
donc le première c'est refuser le 2nd r
c'est réduire on va réfléchir ensemble à
chaque acte de consommation et d'achat
j'achète un nouveau t-shirt nouveau pull
est ce que j'en ai besoin
on se pose simplement cette question si
la réponse est non on remet son acte
d'achat ont leur considère si la réponse
est oui
on n'est pas là pour ce qu'on veut pas
billy's et on est aussi là pour se faire
du bien allez-y simplement vous aurez
apporté un peu plus de conscience dans
chacun de vos axes et je pense que c'est
une étape importante la troisième ère
c'est réutiliser réutiliser ces êtres
paraît super simple et notamment dans
l'habillement
on va pouvoir donner une seconde vie
détourner l' utiliser un objet acheté en
seconde main je vous donne deux exemples
intéressants j'ai je vais signer parce
que l'été prochain je veux un petit
short je vais aller chiner sur les
étagères ce vieux 501 hyper sympa pour
ne pas le nommer
je vais mettre un coup de ciseaux et
j'ai un short super stylé pour l'été
prochain ou un exemple personnel je
reviens d'un voyage à vélo j'ai fait dix
sept mille kilomètres j'ai clairement
pris des mollets je rentre plus dans mon
slim
je vais l'offrir à quelqu'un à une amie
ou une patte à qui ça ira très bien
elle va pouvoir le réutiliser réutiliser
c'est mon troisième
r tout aussi important le quatrième
c'est réparé c'est un réflexe qu'on a
plus dès qu'il ya quelque chose qui
dysfonctionnent qui ne marche plus on a
tendance à vouloir s'en séparer
aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup d'entreprises qui s'engagent
pour que vous puissiez acheter des
produits qui sont réparables
ça veut réparer ça sous-entend forcément
que le produit il est réparable donc on
va essayer de viser ça on a une très
très belle marque que vous connaissez
certainement qui s'appelle patagonia une
marque outdoor qui va pousser même
jusqu'à vous proposer une boutique en
ligne de produits de seconde main qui
ont été réparés pour certains ou pour
d'autres simplement deuxième main et
s'est produit là en fait ils ont une
histoire ils ont une valeur j'ai un trou
dans mon tee shirt je vais pouvoir lui
mettre simplement un petit patch j'ai un
trou dans ma jacket ma doudoune se
trouve là il me rappellera la grosse
cession de peuvent que j'avais fait en
plein hiver et ça me ramène à des
souvenirs on va remettre aussi un peu de
conscience dans nos usages donc réparé
et on a un engagement très fort chez
patagonia et s'il est le nom de le cas
de nombreuses marques aujourd'hui c'est
un dr qu'il faut considérer et enfin le
dernier recyclé recycler c'est loin
d'être le première qu'il faudrait
utiliser c'est vraiment le dernier un
peu la dernière roue du carrosse mais
c'est possible ça suppose évidemment que
les choses que vous avez en main ils
sont recyclables donc c'est pareil quand
je fais mes choix je réfléchis peut-être
à ce que va devenir mon objet demain
aujourd'hui on est super sensibiliser
dans les médias à aux dérives que toutes
nos industries ont et qui sont cause de
grandes pollutions et de deux problèmes
environnementaux et sociaux on peut plus
dire qu'on ne savait pas là l'industrie
de la mode en particulier est dit comme
la seconde l'industrie la plus polluante
après l'industrie du gaz et du pétrole
polluant de comment polluantes par les
pesticides qu'on utilise dans les
cultures comme le coton polluantes par
les colorants chimiques qu'on va
utiliser notamment dans la teinture qui
sont nocives et pour les employés qui
fabrique les vêtements et pour nous
ensuite quand on les porte
et pour lui aussi parce qu'il ya
énormément de fibres synthétiques des
fibres qui sont issus des dérivés du
pétrole donc du plastique et en fait on
a des nano particules de plastique qui
voile autour de nous constamment du coup
on doit
prendre conscience de ça mais le tableau
même si comme ça il paraît il est pas si
noir parce que quand on repense à notre
méthodologie à nos 5 hier on sait qu'on
est capable de faire quelque chose et
qu'on est capable de changer et que les
entreprises s'engagent et qu'on va les
pousser à se bouger
il ya quelque chose de très important
qu'il faut qu'on garde à l'esprit parce
que la mode c'est avant tout quelque
chose qui nous plaît et dans notre
société un vecteur de l'expression de
soi un vecteur de notre personnalité et
s'est du coup hyper important la manière
dont on s'habille on va sortir le cliché
du pull de mémé qui grattent du pantalon
en chanvre du
du truc tie and dye des hippies
aujourd'hui on a des entreprises qui
nous propose de nous habiller et qui
propose de réelles solutions
on a l'exemple de bouteilles plastiques
recyclées qui vont faire des pulls super
stylé on a l'exemple de la fabrication
locale à partir de matières bio éco
responsable de jean qui ont pas fait
trois fois le tour de la planète pour
arriver dans nos placards et qui sont
faites localement en france on a
l'exemple de marc qui valorise des
chutes de l'industrie du textile pour
leur donner une deuxième vie et qu'elles
soient pas vouées à la destruction
donc on a plein de solutions autour de
nous et donc pour vous rassurer
non on n'est pas obligé de sacrifier le
style sur l'autel de l'écologie
et oui la mode peut être circulaire et
elle peut être vertueuse merci de votre
attention
[Applaudissements]